when I was eight years old we lived in
Minnesota really yeah Edina Minnesota
really because you know what else
happened up there yeah Highway to Heaven
bro I get it dude
and I lived in Edina Minnesota Dover
Drive was my street and I remember I
didn't have a lot of friends
so one day I went I was like eight years
old and I go Mommy Daddy
could I have a pet
and they go oh what kind you know I go a
cat
so they got my cat a kitten and I
remember that summer um okay I get
emotionally even thinking about it
I named him Tom because it's like I
didn't know anything else Tom and Jerry
was a thing back then so it was good
yeah so I named Tom and I remember being
in the garage
because that he wouldn't be let in the
house we kind of had like a little pen
in the garage and I would play with him
all day long
for weeks
and then one day I left I came home and
Tom was gone I was freaking out wake up
wake up and my dad looked at me goes He
no longer here
I go what happened I put a pound
no and I go why mommy allergic
and then I started crying and they go
stop crying
and then they left the garage and I
remember sitting there tears there's no
voice like you know no compromise no how
do you feel I'm in no one reason why no
reason why there's no there's I there's
no voice right and I just had to take it
I was powerless right and I just
um
that's like my upbringing in a nutshell
like I just felt like no one heard me
and so that's why I learned to act out
I learned to like you know be funny and
um
do [ __ ] but it's like that's why I have
seven animals now wow you know I mean
because it's like I I love you know I
love animals so much and it's like I
don't know I just I'm just compensating
for that you know I mean I don't know
what happened to that kid that that that
cat but it's just like it just sums up
like why I am the way I am I think you
know I get so angry even thinking about
it oh dude you know man yeah and when he
died two years ago
[ __ ] how long did he live for until his
80. and I loved the man I would do I
loved by your father my dad Oh you mean
you were thinking about the cat I
thought Tom
I'm sorry
that's really funny dude I'm sorry my
dad yeah
when he died I remember like
just look at my brother and my mom
they're just bawling you know what I
mean they're just on the ground rolling
around you know I mean in tears you know
what I mean and I literally was just
looking at not a tear in my eye I was
numb
I was like this is [ __ ] weird what do
I do so I put sunglasses on because I
knew my uncles and aunts were coming in
right because I wanted to pretend like I
was like emotional about it but it's
like I didn't feel anything and it's
like I love it and I miss him but it's
like I know I just have all these
unresolved like feelings toward them you
know
and that's I you know it's like I I
would never do that
to my own child you know what I mean
never and you also beat us and all that
stuff but it's like I don't know man
it's weird I haven't really fully worked
it out but I mean there's reasons why
I'm so [ __ ] up I think you know I mean
yeah man I'm sorry that that happened to
you so it's all right I really am no
yeah that kind of shit's heartbreaking
man that like stuff like that happens to
kids
um do you think because I have things
like that too man sometimes there's like
so much anger built up inside some days
I'm a lot of times I'm okay and then
sometimes I'm so angry
you know what I got I finally realized
the other day while I was angry I
realized
because I've always had like a lot of
like
anger against I think against my mother
I didn't really know my dad that good so
it my mother's the only parent left
and uh
I get angry sometimes because she missed
out on me that's what I feel like yeah
like she missed out on like
whoever I was or whatever was unique
about me or not unique or whatever my
feelings were like she missed out on all
of it you know uh yeah it just she's
still alive right yeah I've seen photos
with her yeah um do you help her like
she needs help and stuff yeah yeah I
help her out you know like with I help
support and stuff like that and you know
I'm grateful that my mom I think she did
the best she could and I think it's like
it makes me sad also that my mom
probably got treated that you know she
only knew what she knew it's a cyclical
thing it's so funny yeah because my
parents my parents had it worse when
they grew up oh way [ __ ] worse you
know I mean I mean I could tell you
[ __ ] crazy stories that they told me
but it's like you know but here's the
thing Theo
I literally still wouldn't change it for
the world
because without all those past
experiences right I wouldn't be who I am
now and I think I'm pretty cool you know
I mean I mean I'm a [ __ ] up guy but
it's like you know I honestly look in
the mirror and I go you know what dude
you I'm so proud of myself
for some of the things that I persevered
through you know I mean this business is
hard
you know I mean there's a lot of
rejection and a lot of like am I gonna
make it and this is years you know now
you know you have the internet and you
know people do Tick Tock videos and they
do different ways to make money but when
I was coming up right you had one way
you do the clubs you become of opener
feature a headliner you get TV spots
hopefully you get a sitcom and that's
pretty much it yeah right and it's like
I just so proud that I was like I came
to LA with no money I didn't know I
didn't know anybody from Show Business
and I crawled my way to where I am now
and there's you know there's a
resilience to that I think you know I
mean I always downplay it and I you know
and I have low self-esteem but it's like
um but at the day I I'm a [ __ ]
Warrior yeah in a weird way right yeah
yeah it's like I did something because a
lot of you know people that have had my
kind of upbringing they turn to drugs
they don't get sober they perpetuate
their behavior and they become shitty
dads themselves or whatever it might be
you know I mean but it's like I chose
to you know get sober frequently during
my life and um try to read books to help
better myself to be a good guy you know
what I mean you haven't given up I'm not
gonna give up you never give up on
yourself yeah no no and um the
resilience of it but it's like it's a
tough business and um so I wouldn't
change anything for the world would you
um let's be real because you're Theo Von
yeah I think it's well I think it just
goes back to that one thing that it's
like uh
if I didn't need
attention if I didn't need like I
remember a lot of my high school
girlfriends and stuff I kept I'm still
keep in touch with their mothers you
know what do you mean like I'm still
friends with their mothers oh yeah yeah
yeah like friends with them yeah like
even more than I talked to the girls
it's like there was just such a pattern
you know it's like I just wonder like if
I would have been yeah I would have been
different but so sometimes I think that
makes me sad but uh no I don't think so
man I think it's probably the same for
you it's like
I chose like
if something in the world isn't going to
see me then I'm going to take the
hardest thing the world has supposedly
which is stand-up comedy and I'm gonna
[ __ ]
make you see me you know yeah I'm Gonna
Make You See Me it's almost sometimes I
think I needed everybody in the world to
love me just because I wanted to get my
mother to love me it's like I just
figured eventually wow it will get back
to her yeah and then I'll wow feel some
type of way you know and I'm not trying
to get into self-pity either I got to be
aware of that because I get into
self-pity no yeah yeah no yeah but I
think man you're a dude there are times
people come up and take a picture like
can I get a picture with you and then
like can you try and look more like
Bobby Lee in the picture they will
literally want me to be like they're
like can you squint a little can you
can you dress like you sell time shares
at a carnival
they're like can you help me yeah yeah
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one